we have a really really big announcement
at the end of the show now I told the
audience here they're not allowed to
text it out tweet it out do any social
media how on a scale of one to ten how
good is the announcement
all right but we'll begin tonight our
top story
as you might have noticed former
president Trump was not indicted today
in fact this morning's grand jury
proceeding in New York City they were
canceled now according to foxnews.com
there is now major dissension at the
DA's office with many speaking out
against Alvin Bragg's political charade
and get this one source telling Fox News
that Bragg is having trouble convincing
a grand jury on potential charges
because of the weakness of the case and
what is spectacular about now think
about this the grand jurors you the
defense does not get a say in a grand
jury proceeding nothing so in other
words they have zero opportunity to
present their side at all that's where
you get the saying you can indict a ham
sandwich right all right so make no
mistake this is a pathetically weak case
maybe the weakest most convoluted case
ever brought before a grand jury and a
quick reminder by the way this is Alvin
Bragg campaigning on a promise to go
after one man Trump one company the
Trump company and one family the Trump
family watch
a lot of people are wondering uh whoever
has this job
are they going to convict Donald Trump
look that that that is uh the number one
issue I'm the candidate in the race who
has the experience with with Donald
Trump I was the chief Deputy in the
Attorney General's office we sued the
Trump Administration over a hundred
times it'd be hard to argue with the
fact that that's that'd be the most
important most high profile case and
I've seen them up front and seen the
lawlessness that he can do and you
believe it should happen
I I I believe we have to hold them
accountable
what you heard there that is not Justice
that is a promise of a political
persecution and here's what Bragg is
trying to do listen very carefully he
wants to take what is a simple
misdemeanor case over a mislabeled
transaction that is two years outside of
the statute of limitations then wrap it
up to a chargeable felony by Trying by
tying in a rarely charged campaign
Finance violation that so many other
people looked at and passed on all
because of a completely legal
non-disclosure agreement an NDA from
seven years ago now I'd like to know how
many ndas might be in the Manhattan DA's
office uh even after the years even the
years before Brad got into office now to
make matters worse the case depends on
testimony from a convicted felon a tax
cheat and admitted and notorious Liar by
the name of Michael Cohn he is the D.A
star witness but don't take it from me
here is Michael cohn's former legal
advisor Bob Costello last night right
here on this show
during that first two-hour meeting
Michael Cohn who as I said before was
pacing back and forth would suddenly
stop in the middle of whatever he was
talking about and turn and point his
finger at us and say I want you guys to
understand I will do whatever the f I
have to do I will never spend a day in
jail he said that at least 10 to 20
times during that two-hour period it was
it was a bizarre Mantra but it made it
clear to us that Michael Cohen was
saying I will lie cheat steal shoot
someone I will never spend a day in jail
well what happened he did spend more
than a day in jail and who does he blame
not himself even though counts one
through seven related to times that
before he even met Donald Trump so he
blames Donald Trump
so will you believe the admitted liar uh
or are you going to believe that
gentleman who does is not a felon and
that's not all according to justnews.com
and John Solomon a memo from 2019
reveals that Cohn told his attorneys
that he quote had no information against
Donald Trump but now cone is telling a
much different story so do you trust
Michael Cohn then do you trust him now
do you believe him now do you believe
him then he admitted that he lied in a
court of law and he pled guilty so
that's because that's that is what the
Bragg jury is going to have to answer
now it's pretty baffling right now
especially when you consider that Alvin
Bragg is famous for handing out plea
deals like candy including reduced
charges get this for rapists robbers
other violent felons and offenders in
fact Bragg previously reduced 52 of
every felony case to a misdemeanor
including many that were caught on tape
on camera in other words a slam dunk
conviction in contrast if Trump is
charged it would be the first and the
only case that Bragg has ramped up from
misdemeanor to a felony that we know of
this seems pretty risky for Mr Bragg
given that he only gets a conviction and
about half the felony cases that he
actually tries Now 49 of the time if he
charges somebody has a trial he loses 49
of the time it is one of the lowest
conviction rates in the entire U.S and
17 points lower than the last EA Brad
clearly he must like to lose anyway and
keep in mind campaign Finance violations
are typically charged at the federal
level but both the doj the FEC declined
to bring any charges against Trump in
2018 a lawyer representing Michael Cohn
issued this letter to the FEC quote in a
private transaction in 2016 before for
the U.S presidential election Mr Cohn
used his own personal funds to
facilitate a payment of a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars to miss
Stephanie Clifford neither the Trump
organization nor the Trump campaign was
a party to the transaction with Miss
Clifford now Bragg is trying to prove
just the opposite despite this clear
exculpatory evidence so why is Bragg
dedicating all this time all these
resources millions of tax dollars to
this convoluted legal case uh I can't
answer that in America Justice is
supposed to be blind in America
prosecutors are supposed to investigate
crimes not people show me the man I'll
show you the crime that was the official
or unofficial motto of the former Soviet
Union and Stalin not the U.S but
apparently that's news to Alvin Bragg
and still it's no longer certain that
Trump will even be charged the winds are
changing rapidly and sources by the way
telling Fox News quote there remains a
real chance that Bragg does not choose
to indict the former president hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else